[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Sirin schönen guten Abend
zusammen Kristin das der wm-thema One
Love kapitänsbindet das entwickelt sich
weiter viel Wut anhaltende
Fassungslosigkeit oder DFB prüft ob das
Vorgehen der FIFA wirklich rechtmäßig
war und natürlich blicken wir später mit
dir auch sportlich aufs deutsche Team
morgen das erste Spiel gegen Japan und
leider gibt es bereits den ersten
Ausfall zu kompensieren später mehr
guten Abend und das haben wir heute
außerdem für Sie in der Sendung
Durchbruch beim Bürgergeld die Ampel und
die Union einigen sich schneller als
erwartet auf einen Kompromiss
langes Ende einer gefährlichen Mission
bis 2024 soll die Bundeswehr aus dem
westafrikanischen Mali abziehen
und erste sportliche Sensation in Katar
Saudi-Arabien bezwingt Argentinien mit
2:1
Superstar Messi startet mit einer
Niederlage in seine wohl letzte WM
[Musik]
beim Bürgergeld da ging es zuletzt hoch
her nachdem die Union Druck machte weil
sie in den Plänen zu wenig
Arbeitsanreize sah und nach Differenzen
auch innerhalb der Ampel heute der
Kompromiss wenn morgen auch der
Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundestag und
Bundesrat zustimmt könnte der Hartz IV
Nachfolger wie geplant im Januar starten
über den Durchbruch und die Änderungen
Lars Bohnensack
über 5 Millionen Menschen sind in
Deutschland betroffen und dabei geht es
nicht nur um die Erhöhung der Regelsätze
für den Kanzler ist das Bürgergeld ein
Systemwechsel wir wollen ja jetzt eine
ganz große Sozialreform beschließen die
dann jahrzehntelang in Deutschland die
Art und Weise der Förderung von
Arbeitssuchenden
beschreibt und das wird uns davon bin
ich jetzt fest überzeugt gelingen die
Regierung wie Union nehmen jeweils für
sich in Anspruch die entscheidenden
Kompromisse angestoßen zu haben
möglicherweise haben die Ampel Vertreter
unterschätzt wie gut abgestimmt und
einvernehmlich in der Sache wir da auch
verhandelt haben Sanktionen kommen
künftig gestaffelt von einem Monat lang
10% Abzug beim ersten Verstoß bis zu 30%
Abzug für drei Monate beim dritten
Verstoß es ist ein Ergebnis des ein
falsches Gesetz der Ampel jetzt in
wesentlichen Systemfehlern verbessern
konnte und auch das schon Vermögen wird
gesenkt von 60 auf 40.000 Euro für den
Haushaltsvorstand und von 30 auf 15.000
für jedes weitere Haushaltsmitglied und
auch nur für ein Jahr
dennoch sehen die Regierungsparteien
entscheidende Unterschiede zum
harzsystem wenn es nach der Union
gegangen wäre dann hätten wir Hartz IV
behalten kein Bürgergeld bekommen und
einfach nur die Regelsätze erhöht das
hätte aus meiner Sicht die
Arbeitsanreize gemindert die ohnehin
schon schlecht war Hartz IV waren und
das war ja das Herzensanliegen der FDP
dass wir mit dem Bürgergeld mehr
Arbeitsanreize haben durch den
Kompromiss dürfte die Zustimmung von
Bundestag und Bundesrat nur noch eine
Formalie sein für künftige
bürgergeldbezieher heißt das dann auch
ab 1 Januar bekommen sie 53 € mehr
dazu alles im Blick hat energy in Berlin
schakundula morgen also der
Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundestag und
Bundesrat aber schon heute der
Kompromiss zum Bürgerwelt warum
Bürgergeld warum ging das dann doch so
schnell ja weil der Zeitdruck einfach
sehr groß gewesen ist ohne eine Einigung
im Bundesrat bis zum Ende dieser Woche
hätte das gesamte projektbürgergeld auf
der Kippe gestanden und damit eben auch
die Erhöhung der Regelsätze für
Langzeitarbeitslose zum ersten Januar
und das wollte sich jetzt nun niemand
zumuten und diese Verantwortung wollte
man sich wieder bei Union noch bei der
Ampel am Ende zu schreiben lassen müssen
in Zeiten von Inflation und Unsicherheit
jetzt gibt es also diesen Kompromiss wo
beide ein wenig Einlenken mussten die
Union kann will das Bürgergeld nicht
mehr komplett als Projekt blockieren und
die Ampel muss dann einigen wesentlichen
Punkten den Forderungen von CDU und CSU
nachgeben und dafür hagelt es jetzt auch
schon Kritik am deutlichsten hat es
vielleicht heute der Geschäftsführer des
Paritätischen Gesamtverbandes
ausgesprochen er sagt die vermeintlich
größte Sozialreform seit 20 Jahren
zerbröselt noch bevor der
Vermittlungsausschuss überhaupt
zusammengetreten ist also da wird
deutlich dass es von linker politischer
Seite eine große Enttäuschung darüber
gibt es die Rundumerneuerung von Hartz
IV jetzt mit dieser Reform nicht gelingt
so die Auslegung die Entscheidung fällt
tatsächlich morgen erst im
Vermittlungsausschuss aber man geht hier
in Berlin davon aus dass sich der
Vermittlungsausschuss doch auf das
einigen wird was in den Vorgesprächen
auch besprochen wurde vielen Dank für
die Einordnung nach Berlin tagunterlage
und auch an anderer Stelle will sich die
ampelregierung Luft verschaffen nämlich
bei der sogenannten winterlücke so
nennen Kritiker der Gas und
strompreisbremse den Januar und Februar
weil die schon beschlossene
milliardenschwere Krisenhilfe des
Staates eben erst ab März greift jetzt
plant die Bundesregierung diese
winterlücke zu schließen mehr von
Andreas
Deutschland im November 2022 Gas und
Strompreise auf Rekordniveau seit Wochen
arbeitet die Bundesregierung an einer
energiepreisbremse eine Kommission hat
Vorschläge erarbeitet jetzt ist der
Gesetzentwurf fertig und sieht vor dass
die finanziellen Entlastungen bereits
früher greifen als bislang geplant im
Januar und den februar ebenfalls noch
mit einbeziehen in die jetzt gültige
dann zu verrechnen der Gas und
strompreisbremse liegt schlicht daran
dass wir die Entlastungswirkung jetzt in
diesen Wintermonaten spürbar und
deutlich werden lassen wollen statt März
soll also schon rückwirkend ab Januar
die Bremse wirken beim Gas Zahlen
private Haushalte und kleinere
Unternehmen dann für 80% ihres
Verbrauches einen garantierten Preis von
12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde beim Strom
sind es 40 Cent je Kilowattstunde was
noch fehlt ist ein Moratorium für Strom
und Wärme und gasperren für diejenigen
verbrauchen und Verbraucher die trotz
finanzieller Unterstützung die hohen
Energiepreise nicht schultern können
auch die Industrie profitiert Gas so der
Plan kostet ab Januar dann sieben Cent
pro Kilowattstunde für 70% der
bisherigen Verbrauchsmenge
Industriestrom gibt es für 13 Cent also
erstmal hat nichts für gut dass jetzt
tatsächlich die Hoffnung besteht ein
schnelles Gesetzgebungsverfahren noch in
diesem Jahr zu haben damit die
Entlastung in dem Fall der Unternehmen
auch zügig passieren kann eine Bremse
nur beim Gas und Strom der CDU fehlt
eine für alle Energieformen gültige
Entlastung Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland die auch sehr hohe
Energiepreise haben bei Öl bei Pellets
die profitieren und schon gar nicht
planbar nicht von dem bisher
vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen der Entwurf
der energiepreisbremse steht jetzt muss
er noch in geltendes Recht umgesetzt
werden
Energiekrise Inflation Krieg bedeuten
Milliardenausgaben für den
Bundeshaushalt im nächsten Jahr darüber
debattiert seit heute der Bundestag am
Ende der Woche soll der Etat
verabschiedet werden Finanzminister
Lindner verteidigte seinen Haushalt für
2023 in wie er sagt Zeiten größter
wirtschaftlicher Unsicherheit die
Opposition warf ihm vor viel zu hohe
Schulden zu machen der Haushalt 2023 hat
ein Volumen von
476,3 Milliarden Euro die
Neuverschuldung liegt bei 45,6
Milliarden Euro
seit Monaten wird an der UN-Mission der
Bundeswehr in Mali gezweifelt jetzt hat
die Bundesregierung beschlossen der
Einsatz soll Enden allerdings erst im
Mai 2024 im westafrikanischen Land sind
zurzeit noch rund
1.200 deutsche Soldaten stationiert sie
sollen Mali stabilisieren und die
Menschen vor islamistischem Terror
schützen zuletzt hatte es aber immer
wieder Streit mit der Militärregierung
gegeben über das Ende der letzten großen
Auslandsmission berichtet Thomas
Reichert
es ist kurz nach zwölf als sich die
verteidigungs- und die Außenministerin
beim Kanzler zum Vermittlungsgespräch
treffen raus aus Mali wie Lambrecht will
oder länger bleiben wie bärbock fordert
das Ergebnis Abzug ja aber mit
Verlängerung bis my24 die soll dann aber
auch für ein Jahr die den Abzug dann
ermöglichen und entsprechend zeitlich
auch abbilden denn so ein Abzug geht
unter normalen Bedingungen eben nicht
innerhalb von wenigen Tagen oder Wochen
die Bundeswehr sollte in Mali die
Bevölkerung vor terrormilizen Schützen
mit spätpanzern und aufklärungsdrohnen
tatsächlich musst du die Bundeswehr
fallen sich selbst schützen den letzten
drohnenflug genehmigte Marlies Militär
runter Mitte Oktober die lange frisst
bis zum Abzug soll helfen dass die UNO
Mission nicht ganz auseinander fällt
das Deutschland jetzt sich als
verlässlicher Partner für die Vereinten
Nationen er weiß und nicht Hals über
Kopf einfach hinwirft und abzieht ist
aus meiner Sicht eine gute Entscheidung
aber natürlich können Einsätze auch
nicht ewig laufen es ist vor allem
Marlies Putsch Regierung die der UNO die
Arbeit schwer macht und russische
Söldner ins Land holte für die Union ein
Grund gerade nicht abzuziehen am Ende
überlassen wir diese Region den Russen
und islamistischen Terroristen
unter den Folgen werden nicht nur die
Menschen da vor Ort leiten sondern auch
wir indirekt wieder durch
Flüchtlingsströme das Ende des derzeit
größten Auslandseinsatzes ist eine Zäsur
die Bundeswehr konzentriert sich
Angesicht von Russlands Bedrohung wieder
mehr auf die Verteidigung des eigenen
Landes und der Bündnispartner
die griechische Küstenwache hat südlich
vor Kreta mehr als 400 Migranten aus
Seenot gerettet zwei Fischerboote zogen
das alte völlig überfüllte Schiff unter
Aufsicht der Marine anland es drohte im
starken Seegang zu kerntern weshalb die
Bergung mehrere Stunden andauerte immer
wieder setzen Schleuser kaum seetüchtige
Boote ein um Migranten in die EU zu
bringen
nach dem Erdbeben auf der indonesischen
Insel Java ist die Zahl der Todesopfer
auf 268 gestiegen mehr als 1000 Menschen
wurden verletzt am stärksten betroffen
ist die Stadt chihandschuhe dort suchen
Rettungskräfte in den Trümmern
eingestürzter Gebäude nach Überlebenden
Indonesiens Präsident vido versprach dem
Betroffenen Hilfe Straßen Brücken und
Häuser sollten so schnell wie möglich
wieder aufgebaut werden
jetzt wieder nach Deutschland die
katholischen Bischöfe liberalisieren des
Arbeitsrecht ihrer Kirche künftig gehen
persönlicher Aspekte wie Homosexualität
Scheidung oder wieder Heirat den
kirchlichen Arbeitgeber nichts mehr an
Vielfalt wird ausdrücklich als
Bereicherung anerkannt 800.000 Menschen
arbeiten für die katholische Kirche in
Deutschland und jetzt muss jedes Bistum
das neue Arbeitsrecht einzeln umsetzen
seit März gilt ja für Beschäftigte in
Kliniken und Pflegeheimen eine Corona
Impfpflicht diese Maßnahme wird aber
nicht verlängert das bestätigte des
Bundesgesundheitsministerium Ende des
Jahres läuft sie aus Grund für die
Entscheidung sei dass die Impfungen eine
Übertragung des Virus kaum noch
verhinderten verlängert hingegen werden
die kostenlosen corona-tests allerdings
für weniger Personengruppen als bisher
etwa Mitarbeiter von Besuchern von
Pflegeheimen und Krankenhäusern
vielleicht haben sie es beim Gang in die
Apotheke auch schon erlebt aktuell
fehlen hunderte Medikamente und das
liegt unter anderem daran dass vieles
nicht mehr bei uns sondern in Asien
produziert wird wenn irgendwas schief
läuft bei Produktion und lieferwegen
kann es eben auch sein dass sie zum
Beispiel in Hannover nicht mehr das
bekommen was sie eigentlich wollten
Oliver deutscher
torhausapotheke in Hannovers Innenstadt
40 dieser fiebersäfte für Kinder waren
bestellt gerade mal zwei werden
geliefert neben den fiebersäften fehlen
unter anderem auch Blutdrucksenker
Antibiotika Insulin sowie einige Krebs
und Magenmittel
wir kennen es jetzt schon seit Jahren
ein zwei Jahren dass wir jeden Tag mit
lieferen passen zu tun haben aber jetzt
verbringen wir doch sehr sehr viel Zeit
damit nach Lösungen zu suchen
rund 100.000 Medikamente sind in
Deutschland zugelassen der Zeit bestehen
bei etwa 300 Produkten Lieferengpässe
Fachleute bewerten die Situation als
angespannt aber nicht bedrohlich wir
haben Engpässe die dazu führen dass
Patienten auf andere Medikamente
umgestellt werden beispielsweise auf
eine Schwester Substanz die hier
ähnliche Wirkspektrum hat aber es muss
kein Patient jetzt hier sagen wir die
Gefahr dass er hier nicht versorgt wird
diese Situation ist noch nicht
eingetroffen weil die Preise für
Arzneien in Deutschland reguliert sind
können Hersteller die drastisch
gestiegenen Produktions Rohstoff und
Transportkosten nicht ohne weiteres an
den Kunden weitergeben
wir brauchen preisunterstattungssystem
das atmet das widerspiegelt das Kosten
wie Moment durch Inflation durch
Herstellkosten die durch die Decke gehen
auch angemessen abgebildet werden können
in den Preisen das geht im Moment nicht
und deswegen steigen Hersteller immer
mehr aus der Versorgung aus
experten erwarten für das kommende Jahr
bei manchen Medikamenten sogar eine
Zunahme der Lieferengpässe ein Ärgernis
für Apotheker sie müssen alternativ
Produkte suchen oder selbst herstellen
was aber aufwendig und teuer ist
kontaktbeschränkungen ja Ausgangssperre
nein so hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht
in Leipzig entschieden es ging um die
Frage ob
corona-schutzverordnungen aus der
Anfangszeit der Pandemie rechtmäßig
waren die kontaktbeschränkungen in
Sachsen waren das auch das Gastronomie
und Sportstätten schließen mussten die
damals in Bayern geltende Ausgangssperre
sei allerdings zu weit gehen gewesen
in diesen schwierigen Zeiten blicken
viele Händler auch sorgenvoll auf das
Weihnachtsgeschäft jetzt gerade starten
ja bundesweit die Weihnachtsmärkte aber
angesichts von rekordinflation von
Energiekrise bleibt ungewiss ob der
weihnachtsfunke auch wirklich über und
das Geschäft anspringt wie es sich in
München und Nürnberg anfühlt bringt uns
Petra Neubauer näher
seit fast
fünf Jahren bietet Ludmilla Mühlbauer
ihre kräuterleckereien auf dem
Nürnberger Christkindlesmarkt an die
Vorfreude bei ihr wie immer groß die
Sorgen diesmal aber auch es kommt zu
jeder Lieferung energiezuschlag und und
und die platzkälte werden auch immer
mehr also
ist schon schwierig 20 Buden bleiben
hier in diesem Jahr leer Corona
Personalmangel und Lieferengpässe haben
den Marktleuten zugesetzt
Ingeborg Gott dir aber ist wieder dabei
einen Teil der gestiegenen
Produktionskosten muss sie an die Kunden
weitergeben am Stand versucht sie zu
sparen bei uns gibt's fast keine Heizung
nur bei wirklich Minusgraden aber wir
müssen sparen beim anziehen und dann
natürlich haben wir jetzt auch die LEDs
ob in Nürnberg oder in München
beleuchtet wird deutlich kürzer erst mit
Beginn der Dämmerung und meist nur bis
22 oder 23 Uhr die Weihnachtsmärkte für
viele gerade in dieser schwierigen Zeit
ein Anziehungspunkt ich liebe die
Stimmung die schöne Atmosphäre das Licht
und dann trinke ich gerne meinen
Glühwein am Strand bevor man Glühwein zu
Hause macht die Preise sind hoch aber
ein bisschen was kann man sich immer
gönnen viele kauffreudige Besucher das
wünschen sich die Marktleute denn für
sie sind diese Wochen die wichtigsten
des Jahres
ja Bescherung auch bei der deutschen
Mannschaft bei der Fußball-WM es gibt
erste Sorgen vor dem Auftaktspiel gegen
Japan der Bundestrainer muss umdenken
Bayern Spieler Leroy sané kann wegen
Knieproblemen gegen die Japaner nicht
auflaufen der Offensivmann für die linke
Außenbahn diesen Ausfall muss haben sie
flieg in seiner Stadt elf kompensieren
das Ziel bleibt der wichtige Auftakt
Sieg bei dem Mission fünfter Stern
normalerweise geht es bei der
Pressekonferenz vor einem Spiel in
erster Linie um Aufstellung und Taktik
doch bei dieser WM ist vieles anders das
beherrschende Thema ist weiterhin auch
hier das fifa-verbot der one love-binde
als erstes kommt bei mir auch fast auch
klar
zu der Bänder zu wollen Laufbänder ist
einfach zu sagen dass die FIFA hat dem
Riegel vorgeschoben und mit so ja
letztendlich mit Strafen auch dann
gedroht und wir alle wussten nicht
welche Strafen dieses handelt und diese
Ungewissheit war das Problem denn gelbe
Karten zum Beispiel als Konsequenz
hätten sie durchaus in Kauf genommen wir
haben ja auch darüber gesprochen gelbe
Karte kannst zunächst mal ist yoke mich
Kapitän dann kommt der Thomas Müller
dann kommt der ist wo er überhaupt kein
Problem gewesen ja und
grunddessen ist es einfach jetzt so wie
es ist und
ja ich finde schade dass man für ja für
Menschenrechte und immer gerade stehen
darf der DFB prüft in dessen ob das
Verbot der FIFA rechtmäßig war unterwegs
den Gang vor den Internationalen
Sportgerichtshof krass die Mannschaft
hat mittlerweile ihr Quartier verlassen
und ist am Spielort eingetroffen bis auf
Leroy sané sind alle fit
und am Mannschaftshotel steht jetzt mein
Kollege Sven Voss Sven wie schwer wiegt
der Ausfall von Leroy sané
sollte schon eine wichtige Rolle spielen
im offensivsystem von Hansi Flick er
sollte zusammen mit Serge gnabry diese
bayerische Flügelzange bilden jetzt wird
wohl Jamal musiala für ihn ins Spiel
kommen auf der linken Seite und im
Zentrum also auf der zehn wäre dann
Platz für Thomas Müller oder
Ilkay Gündogan aber wer auch immer gegen
Japan morgen spielen wird drei Punkte
sind fast eingeplant wir haben es eben
gehört von Hansi fliegt die
Störgeräusche rund um die WM in Katar
bleiben laut Thema Kapitänsbinde wie
sehr schade dass alles den DFB
ja die Kritik gegenüber dem DFB wird
zumindest so lange nicht abreißen bis
die deutsche Mannschaft dann vielleicht
doch noch einen Weg gefunden hat um ein
Zeichen zu setzen wir wissen dass sie
gemeinsam überlegen um irgendwas zu
machen vielleicht kann die
bundesinnenministerin dabei helfen nennt
sie Feser hat vor wenigen Minuten das
Hotel hier hinter mir betreten und wir
wissen dass sie sich mit der deutschen
Mannschaft zusammensetzen will und sie
hat sich heute auch schon kritisch
geäußert gegenüber der FIFA und dem
Verbot der One Love Binde
vielen Dank Sven für diese
Einschätzungen ja der dritte WM-Tag
begann mit der ersten großen
Überraschung dieser Endrunde
Saudi-Arabien besiegte einen der ganz
großen Turnierfavoriten Argentinien mit
zwei zu eins Superstar Messi nannte
diese unerwartete Niederlage einen
schweren Schlag für uns alle
Argentinien der große Favorit erwischt
einen Start nach Plan nach 2 Minuten
fordert superstar Lionel Messi Torwart
Alois und nach dieser Aktion in der 8
Minute entscheidet der Schiedsrichter
auf Elfmeter ein Leichtes für Messi 1:0
es folgen drei weitere Treffer von
Argentinien jedoch dreimal wegen Abseits
aber erkannt es wird klar heute ist der
Wurm drin Saudi-Arabien zurückhaltend
aber mit fast 100%iger Chancen
Auswertung und nach der Pause gelingt
der Ausgleich 48 Minuten mit dem 1:1 und
einem Schockmoment für Argentinien und
es folgt ein weiterer spektakulärer
Moment in Minute 53 Alter Shirin und das
sehenswerte 2:1 Spiel gedreht und
Argentinien findet darauf einfach keine
Antwort mehr
tja unerwartet auch das torlose
Unentschieden der denen gegen Tunesien
das erste 0:0 dieser WM und auch Robert
Lewandowski kam mit Polen danach gegen
Mexiko über ein 0:0 nicht hinaus nach
diesem faul trat der Torjäger selbst an
den Elfmeterpunkt und konnte den
mexikanischen Torwart ottor überraschend
nicht überwinden Lewandowski damit
weiter ohne WM Tor
und ganz aktuell kam gerade noch
folgende Meldung Portugal Superstar
Cristiano Ronaldo ist ab sofort für eins
los sein Club manchester United hat sich
mit sofortiger Wirkung von dem
37-Jährigen getrennt und bei der WM
geht's nachher weiter hier im ZDF live
Weltmeister Frankreich gegen Australien
langer Tag vielen Dank Kristin morgen
übrigens November trüb und grau zum Teil
mit Regen Details gleich von Katja
horneffer in der Halbzeitpause wieder
ein früheres heute journal mit Marietta
Slomka gegen viertel vor 9 Uhr dann für
Sie alle noch einen entspannten Abend
morgen um 19 Uhr sind wir wieder da
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das unwettertief hat
Orkanböen über Sardinien gebracht und
viel Schnee auf der Alpen Südseite es
sieht jetzt südostwärts ab und jetzt
kommt ein neues Regenband heran das uns
morgen nachmittag Regen bringen wird
etwas Regen fällt auch heute Nacht im
Westen aber das wird nicht sehr viel und
am Alpenrand fällt noch etwas
Schneeregen die Temperaturen unter
diesen vielen Wolken sind recht mild sie
sinken auf 7 Grad hier am Niederrhein
und bis minus zwei Grad im südlichen
Brandenburg die Höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen an der Ostsee um die vier
Grad sonst werden 5 bis 12 Grad erreicht
und am mindestens im Rheintal am
Alpenrand kann sich morgen Vormittag
schön die Sonnen zeigen und auch hier in
Thüringen und zwischen Berlin und der
Ostseeküste kommt sie häufiger mal zum
Vorschein sonst ist es meist trüb und
von besten kommt schon dieses neue
Regenwand heran dass sich dann am
Nachmittag weiter auswärts ausbreitet
der Winter zu kommt aus südlichen
Richtungen und dieses Regenband sieht
dann in der Nacht auf Donnerstag weiter
ostwärts am Freitag kommt schon das
nächste Regenband von Westen heran der
Samstag wird dann meist trocken sein und
noch bleibt es recht mild bei fünf bis
zwölf Grad guten Abend